We cannot allow another generation of disabled students
to be educated in segregated settings,
separated from their peers.
There is incredible benefit to inclusive education.
It is the right of every disabled child in Australia
to be educated in a inclusive,
mainstream setting.
That's what we wanna see achieved. Um,
the greens have a policy to do that by 2030
as part of a managed transition that includes parents,
teachers unions
and educational academics
so that every child is able to be educated alongside
their peers.
We have seen again and again that segregation,
uh, leads to violence,
it leads to abuse,
it leads to expectation and neglect.
We gotta work together now to make sure that
the right to disabled people are upheld.
The disabled children are,
are educated alongside their peers
just as they
are in so many other countries in the world.